Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I can't tell fully if this voicemail
is anti transgender or sort of neutral
or what the caller is exactly talking about. So
I want to play it and listen to it together with
you. Let's see if we can figure this out.
Speaker 5:
Hi, David, my name is Ashley.
I wanted to talk about the
transgenders, I think it doesn't take a genius to
realize that when you put a bunch of people who
are from different backgrounds and different
ethnicities together, you're going to end up
with some people that are kind of confusing.
Speaker 1: So I'm I'm noticing the constant
upspeak that's not really bothering me.
It's more, you know, the transgenders.
It's already kind of weird.
Speaker 5: I don't necessarily
think it's about gender. I just think it's
like you just have different looking people
that you're not used to seeing. And I guess this
draws like a lot of conclusions. But I don't think
I don't think it takes a genius to figure out
that when you're born a woman with a vagina,
that means you're a woman for life. And when
you're a man, when you're born with a penis,
you're a dude for life. I
don't think it takes a genius.
Speaker 1: OK, so it's seeming anti trans right
Speaker 5: to figure that out. And if there's
some weird complications, it's probably because
of a cultural difference. And I just think this is
Speaker 1: what is the biggest complication, I
mean, I don't even know what what they're saying
Speaker 5: bullshit. And these
people are really ignorant in
Speaker 1: which people has
a weird voicemail. Right.
Help me pass that out and figure out what what
it's all about. I don't really I don't really
understand what that's what's going on there.
We have a great it doesn't sound good, though,
let me put it that way. Doesn't sound particularly
enlightened or sensitive. We have a great bonus
show for you today. We will be talking about
the America First Caucus, which lasted one day.
It involves Marjorie Taylor
Greene and it lasted one day.
Massachusetts also doing some very interesting
new climate law that if it all goes as planned,
will zero out carbon pollution for the state.
Very, very aggressive and forward looking,
and we will also look at what seems to be Senate
Democrats settling on a 25 percent corporate tax
rate for Joe Biden's changes to the tax plan.
Remember, it was 35 percent previously. Trump
dropped it to 21. Joe Biden was looking at raising
to twenty eight. And it looks as though Senate
Democrats are OK with 25. What I want to talk
about is whether this even matters. And some of
you who have heard me talk about the corporate tax
rate before probably already know where I'm going.
That's on today's bonus, Joe. OK, get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up at Join
Pakman Dotcom. We have a coupon code. The coupon
code is better. Twenty one and very exciting.
Follow me on bit Klout. I rarely am excited about
new platforms. I'm very excited about this. When I
spent the weekend checking it out, go to David
Pakman dotcom slash bit Klout by T Cielo. But
follow me there at minimum. Check out how it
works. I'll have more about it later in the week.